How did Brad Pitt's brutal brawls in
"Fight Club" lead to his cameo in one
of the highest grossing R-rated movies
of all time? Stick around to find out.
Brad Pitt is one of the most
recognizable actors in Hollywood,
having starred in profitable pictures like
"World War Z," "Mr. and Mrs. Smith," and
"Ocean's Eleven." But his highest-grossing
film ever doesn't feature him in a leading
role. That honor actually goes to "Deadpool
2," which made $786 million worldwide.
It's easy to forget that Pitt was in "Deadpool
2" at all — and if you blinked while watching it,
you might've missed him. As the Vanisher, he
has the power of total invisibility — but that
doesn't stop him from suffering a shocking
fate in a tragic parachuting accident.
"Vanisher… maybe the wind
can't blow what it can't see."
"Really?!"
Yes, this is the only time Pitt actually
appears in the film. He never says a word.
Obviously, the gag is that no one
expected a star of Pitt's caliber
to join the cast of "Deadpool 2" for such
a miniscule role. Most film productions
would be thrilled to have an A-lister
like him on board, but director David
Leitch subverted expectations by
giving him a laughably brief cameo.
So how did this zany appearance come about? As
Pitt explained to BBC Radio 1 in August 2022,
he and Leitch have a friendship that dates all the
way back to the "Fight Club" days. He explained —
"Dave's an old friend of mine. He was my stunt
double, starting with 'Fight Club' and all the
way up until about [2004]. And then he went off
and became a really good director, which is rare."
Leitch is best known now as a director
of adrenaline-pumping films like "Bullet
Train," "Fast & Furious Presents: Hobbs &
Shaw," and "Atomic Blonde." But to reach
his level of success within the action genre,
Leitch first put a lot of time into crafting,
coordinating, and performing stunts. Aside from
standing in as Tyler Durden in the late '90s,
Leitch performed stunt work in "Blade" and "The
Matrix Reloaded" — but he still continued to
double for Pitt in films like "The Mexican,"
"Ocean's Eleven," and "Mr. & Mrs. Smith."
After some time, however, their
careers diverged. Leitch pivoted
to assisting with stunt coordination
in films like "V for Vendetta," and
acted as the action coordinator for
"X-Men Origins: Wolverine." Meanwhile,
Pitt starred in critically acclaimed films
like "12 Years a Slave," "The Big Short,"
and "Once Upon a Time in Hollywood" — the
last of which finally got him his Oscar.
However, Leitch's professional relationship with
Pitt has recently come full circle. During a press
event for Leitch's "Bullet Train," in which
Pitt stars as the bumbling assassin Ladybug,
the actor discussed what it was like
to work with Leitch again, saying —
"He trained me for those fights. In a way,
he's helping me develop the character. Now,
he's a director with his own voice and
vernacular. I'm serving him. He's the
boss. So there was a beautiful
symmetry for two old friends."
During a conversation with Leitch and Pitt
for Brut America, Leitch happily noted —
"Our fates took us in different places, and
then they ended up bringing us back together."
As entertaining as it would be, it's very
unlikely that "Deadpool 3" will be what unites
Leitch and Pitt again for outlandish
battle sequences. Instead of Leitch,
Shawn Levy will be directing the third Ryan
Reynolds-starring Deadpool film —and unless some
kind of multiversal plot device changes things,
Pitt's run as the invisible X-Force member seems
to be over. It's also unclear when "Deadpool
3" will actually hit the big screen — due
to the dual writer and actor strikes within
Hollywood, the release date is up in the air.
That doesn't mean that the Leitch-Pitt
collaborations are a thing of the past,
though. "Bullet Train" grossed
over $239 million at the global
box office on a budget of around
$85 million dollars, which is no
small feat. It's a testament to the pair's
successful work together on and off camera.